lui michael je n'ai pas fait trop
attendre ça va avec le motif et excuse
parce que c'était une bête à bon excusez
moi on avait le droit à une bataille
d'eau des bonbons désolé on monte devant
[Musique]
je veux pas dire je suis en promo mais
j'ai participé aux premiers films de
michèle laroque qui s'appelle
brillantissime tout court mais c'est
tiré d'une pièce qu'elle a écrite qui
s'appelait mon brillantissime divorce et
puis voilà c'était venu souvent à tpm
paix shirine c1 c'est un copain à moi ça
va t-il avec les chroniqueurs tu
t'entends bien celle que je préfère
c'est isabelle une fois dans l'émission
où on était en train de discuter avec
cyril chez pas on parlait de promo je
sais pas quoi et d'un coup il se met à
hurler
ouais cyril a rien n'y fait qu'est ce
qu'il ya en aussi parce que dans le
public j'ai une amie et attaque rue qui
sous prétexte que l'ambiance est
détendue que ça y est on a on n'a qu'à
faire comme ci est plus de
téléspectateurs à bas toute façon moi
dès que les gens soient un peu tard et
ça devient très vite des amis quoi mais
c'est le mans qui vient faire la télé je
veux faire un morning live mais le soir
maintenant un événement live
voilà un late night show où je le bilan
reste je suis dans une voiture avec des
caméras
j'ai conduit les gens à par exemple à
une émission puis je leur pose des
questions qu'on va déconner
[Musique]
jean est a lancé un défi se laisse cinq
minutes pour autant antipathique et
après j'ai le droit de leur dire que
c'est pour de faux pas très adroit de
redire que c'est pour de faux
deux secondes de jeu c'est 10 euros
c'est disons non mais je veux pas morte
et bien souvent les photos et appris que
je peux montrer mais quand on demande 10
euros ça plus les jeunes donnent 10
heures dans dix euros ces prêts d'argent
je vous promets que l'état bien 10 euros
donne 10 euros tu as pris une photo
c'est 10 euros donne 10 euros 10 euros
je me disais tu te démerdes veut 10
euros il m'a pris en photo je veux 10
euros mais monsieur je fais pas de photo
avec les gens de couleur je suis désolé
parce que je suis du front national je
peux pas si vous revenez et qu'on voit
pas que vous êtes noir je veux bien
faire une photo avec vous mais moi je
suis du front national dont tu peux pas
faire une photo et une caméra qui
commençaient à trembler ça tu l'avais
grillé mais j'ai vu que tu regardes et
toi t'es pas sérieux mais lui l'épée
dans l'émotion il voyait rien merci les
gars ouais bien sûr bien ok à une photo
un coin mais en revanche vous l'a posté
pas c'est pourquoi vous êtes trop mal
merci les gars défi réussi bah je sais
pas mais en tout cas j'ai pas aimé faire
ça empressé d'aller dire que si une
caméra cachée oui parce que les gilles
tremblay quoi ouais j'aime tellement les
agressent les gens ils ont peur je n'ai
pas demandé s'ils voulaient écouter de
la musique ou à la lna
[Musique]
nana na na nana na na hey le jeu les
voir lors de la veillée vous vois tu
vois tu es dans la voiture le dernier
endroit sur terre où tu peux écouter la
musique que tu veux au volume que tu
veux tu peux même écouter des chansons
de merde
ah bah tiens tiens transition toute
trouvée face à la puissance du port du
rhin
son nom c'est la culture de la betterave
ce matin des soirées où on fait oreo au
haut et au raffinement a pas de troc ya
ce matin mais perd mon boss d'opéra aux
pièces que vous avez quelque chose tu
joues avec je mets tous avec elle je
suis fou un vainqueur tranquille mowag
grau d'agde and bike croqueront c'est
fatal bazooka tapasu corse et solidaire
comme ça fait froid qu'une sûr safer
gars écoute mettons qu'on comprend rien
ce que tu dis que tu mènes d'un message
précis tu vois c'est utaka cool
puta cagoule sauf à cap rouge sauf à
kaboul
[Musique]
j'ai avec moi
haget jeu tu connais birade quoi tu veux
me parler je rentre dedans alors
normalement thermostat dit c'est l'axé
de magna je voulais que tu me fasses au
lieu de dire le morning live mieux tu me
trouves quelque chose on est en touche
pas à mon poste à la place hockey alors
on est 100 magasins
[Applaudissements]
e
il m'a fatigué ce voyage en voiture
est ce que tu peux plus tôt pour le
ramener à à tpm peux-tu me ramener chez
moi
[Musique]
tant qu'on n'aura pas fait cyril hanouna
celui que tu aimes le moins
cyril hanouna le chroniqueur que tu
pourrais pécho avec qui tu pourrais
partir en vacances cyril mais il n'ya
pas que lui un benjamin petit of ya
peut-être gilles verdez avec qui
voudraient pas partir en vacances serait
trompeur tingle dessus dès le matin 10
heures mais c'est tout mais vous voyez
pas que c'est de la merde ils sont pas
du tout comme il faut et sa baie code
mais mais c'est un chien c'est une autre
fête où le plus beau mathieu il est beau
il est tellement bon pour en faire une
table basse il y eu droit comme ça le
plus fayot c'est jean-michel il est
quand même bien bien failli aux anges le
cas le plus le boulard jean michel
sergent michel bon là on arrive dans
cinq minutes on y est
mais c'est vraiment c'est très long
comme voyage quand même c'est très long
parce qu on est quand même parti mardi
et là on est jeudi quoi tu te laisses
pas que tu as passé un membre c'est
fatigant même ainsi à chaque trajet en
taxi il ya autant de choses à faire je
vais pas y arriver
merci d'avoir merci à toi faire ce
week-end au revoir les copains à bientôt
huit ans à l'humide je serai pas ça tous
les jours
[Musique]